how'd you get rich my name welcome back
to neither I'm you guys I'm sorry this
one is going hungry Airways it's pretty
much inspired by HC P that's the same
lovely freakin background sign - that's
in that fantastic alright if you're
familiar with SB it's basically you walk
a lot of stairs whoa what the [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] doors I didn't expect the doors
the door shut itself by by the looks of
it mom I'm sick of that chef you said it
would be candidates [ __ ]
alright the better I guess there's no
turning by now no there isn't
all right so let's lift this candle
alright we can't let the cannibal that's
not my fault
alright listen to this one what I feel a
strange presence in here someone looking
at me are you looking at me boy not just
you but you're going with me because I'm
alone I will never go with you Pele I
will eat your mum's watch take that back
my mom's pie oh okay no I never ate my
mom
oh the boot son of a [ __ ] I hate that
[ __ ] ah ah ah
wow wow I was gonna trust him mine [ __ ]
all right let's keep going I suppose
totally mine [ __ ] stop this [ __ ] stop
all of it ah I think I peed a little bit
but it's okay let's keep going
holy [ __ ]
funny [ __ ] that was short as hell but
I'm
that was probably the most short and
terrifying cups of soda in a long time
son of a penis son of a penis dad yeah
all right I'm gonna hand it a rest all
right
that was horrifying I don't know what to
do now
should I leave the Phillies episode
[Music]
all right I guess you can continue lost
the lights I don't really like
discussing sorry cuz it's really weird I
guess but a lot of you both said it was
really good so I guess I could give it a
better chance and let's do it I guess it
can only become better from here so yeah
we're here
we need the sledgehammer I think a llama
share did you tell these people yes I
did
don't kill people it's not cool it's not
cool
actually no I don't want to play in that
phone I don't know I don't like it
and plus I have to replay and I don't
like replaying don't I have anything
else
alright I don't think I played this one
it's called unreality isn't that lovely
ooh
I like this song it reminds me of
Stefano when we were married about to
get married but we're just going here I
mean we were girl we had a farm up in
the north of Sweden together we're gonna
have a beautiful baby boy called piggy
been a beautiful baby girl called mr.
share but life just don't turn out the
way you wanted to exactly my point
I expected a fricking door of salvation
but
I didn't get it no sir son of a [ __ ]
whatever I get instead I got a stairway
to hell
god damn it
all right okay let's read what this [ __ ]
is about I just work here I don't know
why but I found out this is an endless
nightmare I have been held for days I do
not know how to get out of this cell I
don't want to I am sure you all know
that person have I played this so
contemplating I can't get out maybe
underneath this bed we will find
Jennifer double-triple Jennifer may oh
yeah AJ boom boom boom and by the
bedside Mayo Mayo how do I get out of
here this is a question and one must ask
himself in life many many times oh I see
something let me grab that [ __ ] and
let's just go in here alright no I don't
think I am play this isn't that lovely
hello huh I see some lady getting
wanting some Funkytown
can I jump this I probably meant is to
be sure than 90 alright let's check our
life is this in this room hello
how's life in here lovely lovely lovely
I absolutely adore the water papers
lovely all we gotta do is change the
floor I'm not a big fan on the floor I
prefer
one I prefer Hey oh you tease me with
our sexy legs I thought you were a woman
I am disappointed
all right let's pin a rule this thing I
read angry and see what life is about
now tell me we got nothing
isn't that splendid don't you have
anything for me except your penis no I
don't want your penis what is up with
this place
you can't really run the air it's kind
of weird but that's okay that's how life
is sometimes oh look someone is teasing
me with another penis I think at least
is this a light Danny fire stop doing
that Jennifer seriously did you do this
period Mehrdad disgusting absolutely
freaky freaky through fracking okay
let's go he Oh No but I can't move
whoa oh no he is there lovely he wants
to Mayer
hey I'm sick of your [ __ ] where am i the
man I'm so out of here
I'm out of here then sad the opposite I
don't think alright someone peed their
pants probably not me I can jump here am
I supposed to have a key or something I
don't I don't know we will never find
out
well maybe we will Wow all right it's
not there so let's go over here I
suppose an inch to postage I just did it
like a mouse now this better not be
locked [ __ ]
stop that [ __ ] I'm sick of that just
explode I'm not the hug I'm not that
strong I mean I'm pretty freakin back
but though I'm not bad whatever [ __ ]
where's the father when you need our
love like we were supposed to be on our
honeymoon ridin what that's gay mr.
powner would not appreciate it
all right here it's not safe I know it
there are some strange creature walking
in here I need to get out of here
whatever I am right now I need to get
out and AH Lantern lovely Lantern just
me Lantern gets me in the moonlight all
right we had the key now let's just take
it really freaky to frewcandy easy and
let's get to fake free you had he all
right
I don't even know anymore I lined and I
know once upon a time when there was
cuddly rainbows and unicorns but then
after that it all went downhill what are
you freaking kidding me
what else should I put that dog you
scare me
be quiet please what now you can
disorient me what am i silly dog
invisible dog eh all right lovely maybe
it's in here I think it's in here we can
only hope southern prison
I need more appreciation for my master
bath disgusting it's against God's will
ahh spilling the real pity
all right I'm spinning it I'm gonna spin
it get a nice I'm spinning it there we
go I spun it good yes I did
absolutely fans furnished and locked
what is this receptor for him
what is this receptacle Arnim all right
let's go to it
Oh No let's not go to the receptacle
admin I think we have to go to the
Ritter September column annum Wow
if I was beating the door shut [ __ ]
hate bat off [ __ ] hate oh oh you try
to hide the letter for me Beryl try to
disorient me - can I pull this [ __ ] I
don't know what the [ __ ] I just did but
I pull it and I pull it good go down go
down please get down boy but I pull that
[ __ ] was it up before or was it I don't
know carpets are expensive don't really
need them I'll get out of my way I'm
pissed
potato I don't know what I think about
your potato nevermind
ha ha Buono Buono I go okay we're
heading here hide in here
never mind
like Oh what the [ __ ] three sixes holy
[ __ ] is awesome whoo whoo Oh
Bagon [ __ ] all right I'm too scared to
go nuts up a poker face before poker
face
my papa don't get faced but the [ __ ]
face Gary my kerima know you can read my
poker face she's got me like nobody know
you can read okay ah [ __ ] it hide you
know that [ __ ] come on girl got you cry
that's not crawling good enough pace of
[ __ ]
pace of pee I'm gonna NEA bros before my
neighbours will come in here with a SWAT
team and that's what the [ __ ] is going
on anyway didn't favorite if you enjoyed
it subscribe to come abroad today and
I'll see you next episode I wish I could
call my mom right now
if you hear this
take me out of hippie all right you can
do it
bring it [ __ ] boom
[ __ ] you punch ah son of a [ __ ]